[Music]
on this saturday night tighter rules for
truckers
coveted restrictions for unvaccinated
truckers kick into gear today i have no
plan on quarantine
and unless i'm forced to how it could
affect our already impaired supply chain
pandemic politics vaccine mandates work
but will ottawa support quebec's
controversial tax on the unvaccinated
also tsunami advisory an eruption in the
south pacific is creating waves on
canada's west coast and the loss of a
leader to have the prime minister
steadfastly refuse to acknowledge that
we have a crisis trailblazer alexa
mcdonough's impact on the canadian
political landscape
[Music]
global national reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us we
begin tonight at the canada u.s border
where after an apparent government
flip-flop and much confusion tighter
rules for truckers are now in effect
unvaccinated american truckers cannot
enter canada unvaccinated canadian
truckers must test and quarantine for
two weeks the tighter restrictions put
an estimated 10 000 truckers off the
road but the actual number is likely
much higher it'll also impact the supply
chain and your grocery bill abigail
beeman has our top story
it's called the peace bridge but
cross-border truckers dealing with
changing rules say things aren't
peaceful stress abounds we're just
having issues crossing because we don't
have the proper information and you know
we can't afford to have a fine we're
trying to make money for our families so
like the majority of truckers casey
scheiner is vaccinated now navigating
the arrive can app after a week of
confusion where it appeared the
government was going to let unvaccinated
canadian truckers skip quarantine and
testing but the next day said that
wasn't true you can imagine everybody's
head started spinning and drivers
started panicking the president of the
private motor truck council of canada
says unvaccinated drivers were
dispatched during that window he's
pushing ottawa for a quarantine
exemption you created this confusion
people were dispatched
they shouldn't be punished
for a mistake in communication that was
made by the government the health
minister acknowledged confusion but is
doubling down on the rule change
everyone every every every trucker
entering into canada or or every
canadian or american trucker transiting
to canada must be vaccinated i'm not
taking the shot
i don't trust the shot bridget belton is
helping organize across canada convoy
pushing back against covid mandates she
doesn't know what she's going to do
about the new rules and next week the
u.s implements similar ones since i'm a
dual trucker family
my husband and i both drive means we're
both out of work experts say the impact
will be significant for an industry
already facing challenges the only
alternative is to put people with no
experience on the road which is a whole
other safety issue one of the big levers
that firms have to be able to attract
more vaccinated workers is to pay them
more and in some cases trucking firms
are paying bonuses to workers to get
vaccinated all of these things
collectively result in higher costs
consumers can expect to see not just
higher prices but emptier shelves and
food not as fresh if you feel safe just
go into the grocery store a little bit
more often and buy less at a time so do
the opposite of hoarding the trucking
industry is still pushing for an end or
delay to the mandate the canada border
services agency confirms unvaccinated
drivers crossing the border will be
allowed to deliver their load first
before heading to quarantine even if
that's in another province as long as
they follow instructions and have no
contact with others the cbsa also says
truck processing times took longer in
some places saturday resulting in quote
limited delays colleen abigail thank you
this week prime minister justin trudeau
said incentives and strong measures like
vaccine passports have worked in the
fight against kovid 19 but there are
lingering questions about whether ottawa
should support provinces creating a
financial penalty or attacks on the
unvaccinated ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stephenson sat down with
canada's health minister jean-yves
duclos to speak about that colleen as
new federal projections were released
the country is bracing for unprecedented
levels of covid19
and now pandemic politics are on the
front burner with a health care system
under stress the frustration from
vaccinated canadians who find themselves
under heavy restrictions yet again are
colliding with the anger of the
unvaccinated as they come under
increasing pressure to get the jab this
week on the west block federal health
minister jeaniv duklow weighs in on
whether ottawa would support provinces
in creating a financial penalty or tax
on the unvaccinated as premier lago in
quebec has proposed minister duklow said
that universal health care in canada
means people will not be paying for
access to health care regardless of
their vaccination status but that he
does believe vaccine mandates are
effective
the thing that we do know is that i have
heard from all provinces and territories
including the quebec government that
they are going to continue to abide by
the principle of university universality
of access to healthcare in canada we
we manage healthcare on the basis which
is independent of people's conditions in
particular people's ability to pace
that's the principle on which everyone
agrees are you concerned in something
that starts off as benevolent you're
trying to protect people you're trying
to protect others with vaccination
that actually opens the door though to
serious legal and ethical questions
coercive measures to get people
vaccinated that could potentially
violate the charter of rights and
freedoms does that worry you if
provinces are looking at this kind of
attacks
well thank you and let's be very clear
no one that i think of and how i'm sure
no one that is listening to us today is
thinking of forcibly vaccinating someone
there is we're not obviously in this
world however vaccine mandates work
minister duklow will also address
whether there's a timeline to send the
province's those billions of promised
health care dollars from the federal
government he'll also talk about
concerns some canadians have around
their privacy with the public health
agency's use of cell phone data and
whether the federal government would
reallocate some of the pcr tests that
are currently being used at the border
now to provinces who are strapped for
them colleen
thanks mercedes and of course you can
watch the full interview with the
federal health minister tomorrow on the
west block right here on global
major developments are expected soon in
the novak djokovic deportation saga down
under
[Music]
[Applause]
a last-ditch effort by djokovic to stay
in the country and defend his grand slam
title will be decided by a federal court
today the world number one was taken
back to hotel detention on friday and is
preparing to appeal immigration minister
alex hawk's decision to revoke the
tennis star's visa for a second time
over fears djokovic could encourage
vaccine hesitancy in australia djokovic
is not vaccinated against covet 19 and
he faces immediate deportation and a
three-year ban from entering australia
if he loses
a tsunami hit the south pacific island
nation of tonga following an undersea
volcanic eruption it also triggered
tsunami advisories as far away as
coastal british columbia and areas of
the u.s west coast satellite images show
the eruption even from space you can see
the huge plume of ash rising into the
air the volcano was roughly 65
kilometers north of tonga's capital and
the rippling effect forced warnings in
japan as well as advisories in new
zealand and on this continent from
california to alaska
in canada tsunami advisories remain in
effect for the outer west coast of
vancouver island and the juana fuca
strait some cities and towns closed
beaches and coastal roads as a
precaution
another wild winter storm hammered the
maritimes overnight and again today with
heavy snow freezing rain and wind gusts
of up to 120 kilometers an hour
the storm is the second weather bomb to
hit in a week today tens of thousands of
customers across nova scotia and new
brunswick woke up to no power up to 35
centimeters of snow could fall before
the storm is over tonight the nor'easter
is taking aim at newfoundland and
labrador where heavy rain and blizzard
conditions are expected
another winter storm tracking towards
southeastern and eastern ontario could
complicate the province's back to school
plan next week in-person learning
resumes monday and that's when the storm
is set to hit bringing up to 20
centimeters of snow to toronto and 25
centimeters to hamilton and oshawa the
storm is likely to cause major
disruptions including school closures
and bus cancellations
a monster storm is sweeping across the
u.s and it's dumping snow in several
states and bringing the threat of a
major ice event to parts of the south 64
million americans in 26 states are under
some kind of weather alert and the
winter blast is expected to bring minus
40 degree wind chills to new england and
possible flooding to new york here's
jennifer johnson
this wicked winter storm has already
dumped snow at a rate of 2.5 centimeters
per hour from north dakota to illinois
causing whiteout conditions and
hazardous driving close to 80 crashes on
iowa's highways alone in a four-hour
period late friday out in the open
spaces out there everything drifts over
so it's real hard to be able to get
through
now the storm is headed east where
forecasts of snow and ice as far south
as georgia have millions on edge the
storm is happening now the storm is on
its way now and so our crews have to
react now
crews in north carolina are covering
power lines in anticipation of ice
buildup and widespread outages promising
to do their best with many workers out
sick with covid we're doing everything
we can humanly possible based on our
limited resources of trucks
virginia's governor has already declared
a state of emergency after hundreds of
drivers were trapped for more than 24
hours on a 40-mile stretch of interstate
95 last week crews have pre-treated that
busy highway for the past two days
atlanta is also getting ready in 2014
five centimeters of snow brought traffic
to a halt an event still known as
snowmageddon this is about public safety
the public interest and making sure that
the business of the city can continue
the fast-moving storm is expected to hit
the mid-atlantic sunday before moving
northeast into new york new england and
southern ontario bringing snow gusty
winds and bone chilling temperatures
across the region
jennifer johnson global news washington
we have a developing story out of texas
where police say hostages are being held
at a synagogue a swat team is on scene
in colleyville not far from the dallas
fort worth international airport the
situation unfolded during a morning
service that was being live streamed on
facebook and the video has since been
removed it's unclear how many people are
being held at this time residents in the
area of the synagogue have been told to
evacuate fbi negotiators are said to be
in contact with the person in the
building possibly a suspect there are no
confirmed details of a motive
vigils to remember the life of a young
irish teacher continue across ireland
and the uk this weekend
in the city of limerick hundreds
gathered at this candlelight vigil near
the college where 23 year old ashley
murphy studied murphy was found dead
wednesday after going for a run on a
popular canal side route in her hometown
irish police say they've identified a
person of interest
the national response is reminiscent of
sarah everard's murder in the u.k last
year she was walking home when she was
kidnapped and killed by a london
metropolitan police officer
alexa mcdonough has died coming up the
legacy of the first female leader of the
ndp
[Music]
former ndp leader alexa mcdonough has
died at the age of 77 following a
lengthy battle with alzheimer's disease
as eric sorenson reports she's being
remembered as a strong leader a
political pioneer and a stalwart
supporter of women's rights in canada
who does the prime minister think he's
helping by ignoring the crisis alexa
mcdonough was an outspoken trailblazer
for women and for social justice i have
a job to do with nova scotia the first
woman in canadian history to lead a
major political party with the nova
scotia ndp in 1980 a lone woman
whirlwind in the all-male nova scotia
legislature she had to deal with parties
which thought
that raising issues like woman's right
to choose was a way to bring her down a
lot of influence a lot of changes flowed
from her own determination she shocked
new democrats when she won the federal
leadership in 1995. someone
has got to pull the wool
out of those liberal ears
she was the first woman leader in
canadian history to build a federal
party into something bigger electorally
more than doubling ndp seats in 1997 and
establishing a strong presence in the
maritimes that would last a generation
you took this campaign right over the
top
right into the history books
for mcdonough politics was less about
the pursuit of power than bringing
social change long overdue she was an
early advocate for gay rights and
support for racial and visible
minorities she was for the little guy
and against big money in politics half
million dollars you're in no problem
instant access she always did it with
integrity and with principle and i i
really think
we have to remember alexa for that and
what she
contributed to a good kind of politics
in canada what on earth is going on here
she is remembered fondly by political
friends and foes ndp leader jagmeet
singh posted that mcdonough championed
women in politics and never backed down
from a challenge former mp megan leslie
remembers a role model she
really was this leader
who
would
boldly go and then turn around and reach
out her hand and bring others with her
she set the stage for even greater
success for the ndp and the next leader
jack leighton
we tell alexa mcdonough there's no
orange wave in 2011. she brought back
the party to party status and to a force
in the house of commons and without her
that probably would not have happened
one confidant called mcdonough a
restless personality always looking
forward to the next cause
alexa mcdonough's cause was always to
make canada a just and welcoming nation
eric sorensen global news toronto
foreign affairs minister melanie jolie
is heading to ukraine as concerns mount
over a possible russian invasion jolie
will depart for kiev tomorrow where
she'll meet with ukraine's prime
minister and deputy prime minister
she'll also visit with the 200 canadian
troops stationed in the country to train
security forces her office says the trip
is to show canada's unwavering support
for ukraine sovereignty russia has
amassed an estimated 100 000 soldiers
and weaponry along its border with
ukraine jolie's week-long trip will also
include stops in paris and brussels
a scoop or a scam ahead how to treat
financial advice on social media
[Music]
you've probably heard of social media
influencers but what about thin
influencers
they talk money on tick tock instagram
and twitter some are savvy some are
scammy and gaviola has more on how you
should treat financial advice on social
media in part two of our influenced
series
pf's and mutual funds are exactly like
megan marco
and kate middleton
she's known as mrs dow jones dishing up
tips on managing your money without
lecturing or being boring
i started to make content
tying together pop culture and you know
i have a sense of humor
um with these financial lessons and
posting it and it just took off she's a
rising star amongst influencers social
media influencers who talk about money
they don't look or sound like your
cookie cutter bay street or wall street
types and that's the point reaching a
younger mostly millennial and gen z
audience i'm not you know an old white
man in a suit lecturing them on how they
shouldn't spend money elise fulford
studied kinesiology before finding her
groove as a finfluencer with nearly half
a million followers on tick tock she
aims to put the person in personal
finance sharing the story of how she
graduated university with 35 000 worth
of debt
i had a lot of guilt and shame around
that debt influencers talk about savings
retirement and crypto like former tax
lawyer handel kim his day job is in
commercial property influencing is his
side hustle his go-to platform tiktok
and he's most excited about blockchain
the technology that makes bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies possible the
blockchain technology i genuinely
believe is going to change the world
based on the research that i've done and
so be part of the journey it's really
exciting but there is a murkier side to
all of this kim kardashian's being sued
by investors for pumping ethereum max
which isn't affiliated with ethereum the
world's second largest cryptocurrency on
social media last year the project is an
alleged scam securities regulators safe
influencer popularity is on their radar
social media has been an important
democratizing source of information but
it it also comes with misleading
information finnfluencer red flags
include impossible promises guarantees
that you'll get rich quick contests and
time limited actions that require you to
part with money or personal information
right away
before you put your money into anything
cross-reference what you've just heard
or read do other credible sources back
things up do your research and check the
credentials of the person giving you
information information is the currency
on social media but when it comes to
your money financial basics still apply
ann gaviola global news toronto
next china going to extremes to ensure a
coveted safe olympics
[Music]
the beijing olympics are set to begin in
just 20 days organizers are confident
everything will be ready on time but the
concern isn't about venues it's about
the omicron variant and there's more
than gold medals at stake so as mike
joley reports china is going to extreme
lengths to prevent kobit 19 from
spoiling the games
at 83 years old china's father of skiing
can still get down the hill and when
called upon by those tasked with
boosting interest in the upcoming
olympic games he's as smooth as skis on
snow water wait i think china will
receive more medals than past years and
will have more champions he says
china is pulling out all the stops to
show the world they're ready to host the
games and safely entertain at 2 000
athletes and the 25 000 support staff
traveling with them the olympic village
will be a tightly controlled bubble with
few opportunities to socialize
automation will play a huge part in that
with meals either lowered from an
overhead grid in the dining hall or
prepared and packaged by robots olympic
gender and sports author helen jefferson
lenski says beijing has learned from the
outbreaks that flared up at the 2021
games in tokyo on the other hand it
wasn't the total disaster that a lot of
us predicted it would be
and some of that had to do with the
bubbles and some of it had to do with
vaccines and so on
china isn't leaving anything to chance
and its zero coveted approach has led to
vast and restrictive measures for
chinese citizens living all over the
country ahead of the games
a third city was put into lockdown this
week impacting nearly 20 million people
a massive effort to disinfect surfaces
and control the virus is underway with
testing sites set up at universities to
complement the country's vaccine booster
program
authorities have also gone to extremes
welding the door shut of a man suspected
of bringing kovit into the city of xi'an
and locking employees and customers
inside a shanghai store overnight after
someone was identified as a close
contact with a positive case there is a
global protest
about china even hosting another
olympics it was bad enough in 2008
and their reputation in terms of human
rights violations was very poor then
it's got worse since 2008. but china
doesn't want to talk about any of that
the games are all that matter now mike
durley global news toronto
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm colleen christie
tonight's your canada is cape breton
island in nova scotia we would love to
see your corner of the country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
i'll see you back here tomorrow have a
good night
[Music]